i don't understand how your position is
tenable if gender and sex are separate
so my only point that i i would like to
make is when you say men's and women's
sports yes
i would like that to just simply mean
people who identify as men people who
identify as one but it doesn't um not
right now no but it could and it doesn't
because of biological differences sports
are separated due to biological
differences right now yes um and there's
a reason for that well i mean for the
safety of women
um well and then it just goes back to
the same argument we kind of
we went back and forth on the data of
does it actually harm women in the sense
of like because i mean obviously you
mentioned like broken orbital bones and
all stuff in combat sports which
injuries are going to happen in the
realm of obviously an orbital bone is a
pretty serious i mean that's a that's a
bad one but
injuries are going to happen in the
realm of combat sports citing that let
me ask you this because
do you not believe that there would be
more injuries occurring in contact
sports if biological men just compete if
there are no men and women's divisions
do